[Music]
hello little liars and welcome to et
live we are joining you once again for
the Rosewood run down and we Anna
gelareh and Katie crowd and joining us
today is the one the only Janel Parrish
what an episode I know that you last
night and I go right into our three
biggest bombshells and you guys that are
watching make sure you're leaving all of
your questions for Janelle because we
are going to get her to answer them um
but let's start with your intro to last
night's episode you have all the girls
around and sassy Mona is I'll be honest
my favorite moments the best Matt aren't
I I love it I'm not only am I here but
I'm going to like help you guys out fine
a choice of words of words little brat I
know sorry I always bring out you know
that rat thing oh let's take a look at
this question who's that
that was me I am like within it an
invitation motive knows about the game
why because we need her help Emily she's
brilliant she knows the answer before
you even ask the question well the
question is why you waited so long to
ask and for that I have no answer Pomona
this isn't Trivial Pursuit there's a
missing body and it stopped focusing so
much on the dead body and put your
attention on the live one what you think
you know who ad is I have a short list
starting with Jenna Marshall and ending
in Mary Drake okay you know what
we don't need your series and there's no
peace on that board that looks like you
I guess you're forgetting who replaced a
shattered windshield once you peel
Dunhill off of it which makes me an
accessory to your crime and if you think
I'm going to leave my fate in your
fumbling hands you've been smoking the
tree don'ts not those raisin I'm writing
a Jetix oh I'm so terrified lon
kind of walk us through Mona's headspace
in that moment in that moment right now
I think she's really enjoying like
showing up and just being like you know
you didn't ask my help but you need it
yeah I'm I'm the help that you didn't
know that you need
and you guys are all idiots and Here I
am but there's also like a little bit of
meeting their approval to know like
she's only wanted to be a partner why
don't you ever let me in the group and I
think so
it don't know it's kind of fun to play
that fine line of like I want your
approval but I'm not going to show you
it you know and I don't know I just I
just love how they're always just like
ah Mona just like that's right here I am
bit by the way yeah did you miss this
part for me let me show you in a way you
missed do we trust Mona do we indeed
right I mean that's that's always the
biggest question I mean I feel like
that's what's fun about our character is
that you you you just make a decision
and then she turns around and surprises
you yeah like you're like okay I finally
trust her and the end of the episode
though a little bit Shady right well
we're gonna get you out of that no
worries about that oh I can't wait you
guys can't wait guys but of course we've
got to talk about the musical no man
waiting for it okay
just ride the wave of black how did
Marlene first approach you with this
idea you know actually it was Oliver
because he directed the episode right so
he came up to me um probably about a
month before we shot it and it was like
okay I have this idea it's a little
crazy how would you feel about singing
and doing you know like a crazy music
nightmare and I was like um yeah I mean
you had me at singing I'm down so yeah I
told me jailhouse rock and I was sort of
like how I gonna how does that like work
with a nightmare
yeah situation and he told me his his
whole you know idea of it and we got
this amazing choreographer and I saw the
set and I was like oh my god this is
bringing like Chicago vibe yeah that's I
mean that I love it I mean I know I'm a
Broadway baby you know like my heart is
always in theater so I loved it it was a
really fun day what was it like working
with Ian Harding and Lucy that day it
was a amazed by all my online I know if
we had a great time I actually think
that the person who enjoyed the
theatrics of it all the most was Ian
right he was just enjoying he'd loved
all of it is so much fun yeah we had a
great day that day well you know well
you told me an interesting fun fact
about that where you recorded it yes we
recorded it in the ad our booth which is
not even not a renewable video booth but
it was no it's kind of funny I was just
like walked in there and they put my cup
and they were like okay let's just take
it like alright here we go
like how many cakes was that um to get
it to singers get that down I think we
did we we only did a few maybe four or
five takes it was kind of a quick a
quick day yeah I mean that I'm gonna
Sabri watch it I need a little snip yeah
that can we play that clip ah Mon let's
get this over with your toilet paper
starting to wilt
[Music]
jumping in the sand
[Music]
three I'm like it's not funny it was so
different for PLL Wow and the fun thing
about it too is that I think a lot of
people were just like oh oh it's on what
am i watching because it's like right
now right a commercial-grade
and then it's just like oh there's a
musical number that I love that I love
that we were able to shock them and be
like final season you weren't expecting
this here you go musical dream sequence
yeah it was giving me the newer episode
flashback yeah I love that as well
because I know I was speaking with your
old costume designer Mandy line yes film
at episode in order to achieve so many
different shades she wore you guys in
like crazy color yes what colors was on
set when you were filming you know funny
another fun fact is that we shot it
intending for it to be in color so I'm
just wearing blue and later on when I
saw Oliver she was like you know what
tried it in black and white and loved it
so we're doing it black and white I was
like awesome great choice it looks so
good yeah um before we get into our last
bombshell we have some questions coming
in already for you Oh fun okay so Megan
says will Ali baby arrive before the end
of the show oh that is a good question
I'm going to say what I always say which
is you'll have to wait I know I was
still bad at interviews when I go like
can't answer questions oh no it's fine
I'm going to find the most creative ways
to be like haha doesn't everybody want
to know about you and one egg Ryan
first of all right I understand why you
would ask this but like I'm so upset
right now he wants to know if Mona's
going to die
another million-dollar question I mean
yeah that's that's always you know who's
going to die in Rosewood people die
people come back to I mean I've been
dead already yeah true that have to
again counselor and see we only have
three more episodes so you find out all
the answers you've ever wanted I feel
like that like since you've already been
killed off ones I have to say that she
has immunity
I've been said I've been a ghost and all
the things we've been a yes I have we've
got to talk about the fact that you're
on screen besties had a really big
moment last night miss Hanna Marin
I know may be getting there did you see
the be coming and ones that actually an
engaged
are there going to be real rings I'll
tell you that in the next episode
somebody gets married
however whatever check out how you will
is it I was already engaged I'm sneaky
girls kind of get answered man guys more
dancing tryout no but let's talk about
that engagement yeah I I knew it was
coming I read the script and I still was
like watching the show with my dog being
like oh my god I'm like holding her like
this
I love halo yeah kind of my favorite
Clell couples well they're so cute and
they have such good chemistry amazing
chemistry I mean it also helps with
their best friends well you know should
weary watch the moment oh my gosh
oh oh I do it here's well I'm ready did
you really mean what you said what to my
mom
can you really yeah I need to know I
don't know if you said it just to
distract her pana I would marry you
right this second if we design a bear
whose license
I've killed rewatching
do you always well I came prepared just
in case people I know I mean I do hope
that we get anything
like me
[Music]
like me
we connect your spray how cute is that
they're just perfect they're like the
most perfect couple
yeah when you said can I kiss the bride
I was like no what well I think they're
just sealing in that their plant hair my
yeah yeah yeah I wasn't actually the
wedding because no I and there were some
questions like wait was that the wedding
event no I think you're having a sweet
moment of like this is what's to come
you know they're sealing the deal that
they're going to go down this road
together yeah another twosome that we
loved last night was Mona and Emily I
love it I was yeah I was seeing so many
fun tweets last night being like wait is
this the next couple there we go fun and
make a great couple you know I mean I'd
ship it but not really because I'm so I
know ever since like Emma said I just
love like Simona's like just trying to
sell it emily is just sitting there just
like rolling your eyes like just I can't
believe this is happening now just get
your hand off my hand stop talking
what could you tell us about the
father's identity of the baby obviously
your phone is involved well most on the
quest for nazar and asked to help find
out who ad is and so a lot of that has
to do with like whoa who who did this
whole you know Alison Emily baby
situation so she's definitely on the
quest to find out you will find out more
on that next week dun dun dun so many
fans right are you going in your
comments a lot of are saying that Mona
is ad and we're going to get to that but
I got to disagree with you guys right
now well we saw Mona with this layer and
I feel like any time that we think of
Mona and a layer we go back to the very
beginning of yellow yeah and her layer I
think that she's actually a genie - he
didn't habits die hard and also she was
like puzzle Gigi I'm mark Repp she needs
to see everything up she puts all the
pieces together so I think everybody
that's on her board you know it all has
to do with who's ad I've been asked to
help play this game and figure out all
the little pieces of it is there some
shady business going on maybe so but I
think from last night's episode you know
you guys can can kind of be your own
detective and see what you think but you
know I think she's just trying to play
the game
to do so well and also like she's the
one that took the photos of it I don't
want people to think that like oh my
gosh maybe she made the boardgame know
she was so fascinated by it
she's very fascinated by this board game
but what's it going to do to her is the
question will Mona how to turn will she
have a turn in the board game well let's
just say that the darkness of the board
game starts to bring out a little bit of
a darkness in Mona you know like you
said old habits die hard she even said
it earlier like I'm scared to touch it
you know I mean I was an addict as well
that's you playing with people's lives
and being involved in being you know the
puppet master and I think you'll start
to see over these next two episodes it
does it does take a little turn in Mona
anyway talking about everything that's
up on that board well the girls discover
that Mona has been piecing all this
together and for how long they will
start to figure it out yes is that a
good thing or a bad thing very soon it's
a little bit of both okay I did I can't
imagine that they would be surprised
like when we go into like Mona's house
and we saw that she was putting this all
together I was just like yeah okay sorry
like how else do you think that she's
like one step ahead of the girl and gets
where the way that she does it yeah and
her logic of it that is surprising I
think that she's a big fan of homeland
love it I love it Nerva says i think
Mona is trying to search for ad herself
and doesn't want to involve the girls
because they act first and think later
so they may ruin her plans to find out
who ad is I think a lot of that has has
truth to it Mona has kind of figured out
that she works better on her own and I
think she's worried that sometimes the
girls slow down her progress and she has
her own way that she likes to work in
her own way that her mind works even if
it's a little weird and twisted
sometimes and you know she's got her own
reasons and you'll start to figure that
out as time goes on but yeah Mona likes
to do things on her own well one of the
things that I'm desperate to figure out
is what's Mary Drake steal she returned
in last night's episode of Mary Drake I
know I love Mary Drake so much I want to
trust Mary Drake
look she's just like pops out of the
back of a car Mart you know she's in
hiding and I just love whenever she
talked to Spencer and you see like the
hurt in her eyes about what happened her
I feel bad for her yeah I do can you
give her
I don't know if I do the listening
session trustworthy because at the very
beginning of the episode you think that
Mary drink is ad I know again I think
that's another thing that makes the show
so fun is like you don't know who you
can trust right now the girls think they
can trust Aria and they don't understand
well they don't even know but like we
know her reasons than what she's doing
but if they found out tomorrow like you
destroyed this crib and you did this and
you did that like they would be
heartbroken right but it's that whole
thing of like who can you trust but why
are they doing what they're doing field
though like Spencer is catching on to
Aria because they had that phone call
last night and at the very end of the
phone call you see Spencer's face and
then the earring thing right yeah can
you team like that i lo up pretty soon
yeah well we saw him at the elbow that
like it looked like Spencer she's like
I'm done I'm done with you yes
ridiculous you'll start to see all of it
come to heaven except aside the girls
going to fight cat fight inroads letter
cat fight we've had so many can go right
people slapping people Spencer tried to
choke me out oh my god I know we always
joke that we have like Spencer and I
always have physical altercations yeah
but we also like still kind of like each
other and you're like I your brain
though cuz it was rated mark yeah bring
me back so which leads us to our pretty
little flash battle of the week this is
a good one this is a really good one so
we pulled this clip from season 5
episode 11 and it has to do with Mona
and Aria and eater yes oh my goodness I
know so let's take a look at that I'm
going to see what she remembers i oh
jumpin Mary
[Music]
maybe you won't believe this but I'll
say it anyway when she finishes with me
she'll come after you and the others she
can't trust you anymore not after Cyrus
and not after New York what about New
York I know some things and I can guess
it's another done done okay and what can
I judge Aria wanker I completely forgot
about and you're like oh we shot that
that's right what was my next line yeah
I couldn't you know yet what did she
whisper she didn't was Brittany where we
meant they told us that they didn't want
us to know and make up our own choices
about what she said the one she's
whispering she's just like are we gonna
find out though is that one of the
answers that we'll get i don't know i
think that that was less more like less
less more less about like the big
picture and more about like her saying
like you don't deserve to be here nobody
likes you you do you don't deserve my
brother you know it was more of a
bullying moment I think for Mona as
opposed to like this is part of this big
a secret well okay one of the my
favorite things about last night's
episode was in the dream sequence
when mrs. Hastings called out our ever
being a selfish [ __ ] I loved it I loved
it because like as much as I've always
loved Aria I do feel like she's being a
shady [ __ ] right now
she told me a shady [ __ ] right now very
selfish yes yes very selfish and it's
like everybody has secrets everybody has
things that they don't want out there
what makes your secrets that much more
important than they have your friends
yes
so absolutely cool Ari I'd have my Cobra
what about New York and Aria shooting
someone are we gonna fit yesterday
whenever we got away with murder
really
many of the PLL's have gotten away with
murder they don't really I just helped
to make the show that much juicier you
know yeah yeah I don't I don't know what
I mean I kind of feel like now we've
moved on to the next ad saga I thought
one is sort of been like that was a
story for then and this is a story for
now of like who is this new ad well
let's get through our Rosewood fast five
because that will lead us into our agent
talk so once again we have been asking
so many of our favorite PLL cast members
these same five questions and let's see
how well you do
okay number one who's the very first
person you ever felt was a I guess it
was me yeah yeah yeah yeah everyone I'm
saying that I'm okay no no book fan yes
I was and I knew it was coming up what
about your craziest most jaw-dropping
moment of the whole series of the whole
series Maya's death I'm inspected made
me sad we're gonna bury a lot of that
word yeah sad about that that one broke
my heart I mean it was Emily's first
like real love you know relationships
just sweet I didn't do anything deserve
it deserve to die sighs uh who is a
couple that you shipped on the show but
it can't be one of your own who a couple
that I ship in the show but it can't be
one of my own well I guess it was it
would be Miya Miya Emily yeah to tie
that story but really I really did love
that relationship with this week the MSN
fans are screaming right I'm sorry I
decided Amundson bad it's just back in
the day like I really loved I loves our
relationships yeah yeah one word to
describe the finale one doesn't say
jaw-dropping jaw-dropping there's a
hyphen in there okay jaw-dropping okay
okay and lastly what was your reaction
when you discovered ABS identity
brilliant just Marlene's brilliant
that's a good that's a good description
okay so it makes it all much sense and
you'll see I was going to say did you
see it coming
no really but once it's revealed and you
start to kind of like because it gets
revealed and then it gets explained
which is what I like right
because you don't just want a big reveal
you want to reveal then you want to put
why right now why how and it's just you
start to realize once once you started
getting all the pieces kind of put
together you start to realize that there
were hints and trails and everything
just kind of clicks and that's that
moment that you're like genius dodging
is the finale going to be like that one
episode where it was the summer of
answers where we had the big reveal in
the beginning and then the rest of the
episode is filling in the piece in the
pieces um I don't know if this finale is
like any other finale we've ever had
it's it's laced with omage as to the
cast to the writers to the fans who've
been there since the very beginning it's
beautiful it it's funny it's bittersweet
and yes there are answers but it's all
just kind of like interwoven together to
make this beautiful gift for the fans I
don't know how else to explain it
Brendan Robinson was here and he told us
that you can trace back
ADEs identity almost at the very
beginning yeah make sense there have
been breadcrumbs that I think I think
fans will really enjoy one thing no
enhancement they can go back and
re-watch it be like oh oh I make that
make sense you know is there one season
or maybe one episode that you can drop
right now for us to go back and pay
attention to I don't know if there's one
specific season or episode I'm in and
they're kind of all like sprinkled in
throughout the series
I can't maybe the brilliant I think we
need to bring up our suspect for oh
because these are our status updates
these are all the people that we think
can be kinda Shady
oh and well I know which is everyone in
row beer on it yeah Madonna right now
the four girls are on it yes they're on
it right oval of course they're on it oh
I'm not worried do you think that we
need to be paying attention to in these
next three episodes that is excellent
I'm still going through it haha and
where is Jesus Jason yes we asked them I
love you Jane turn up with this like
routing long hair you're like hey Dad
what's up on the board I mean let's just
say like those are some pretty great
faces see what civil see what happens
well we want to reduce some of these
comments and maybe this will come back
some I yes Chloe um Chloe says hi Jane
what do you think about the Spencer LT
Wayne yeah Mary Jane Center twin theory
and you know I've heard some pretty
great theories they're all some pretty
good series ah happen okay what happens
kt9 said for the past couple weeks we
really do stay fit Spencer has a twin
and that the more that you pay attention
to it and the one scene in particular
that we skipped us off yeah I want to
know what it is that they're before that
Wayne okay there were a little sprinkles
but when we saw I can't she's mandate
harangue with with Ren because she
looked different she looked tired babe
not address differently is under
investigation for murder is very true
that's true you know what I mean I'm not
really blood in that case either so many
other theories Olivia says ad is Paige
Renee says I came Mona killed Charlotte
these are all interesting theories I
wonder why she thinks up should she
think that I mean I think that in this
case everybody is a suspect in Rosewood
by the way everyone's done some really
shady things yeah so why not suspect
everybody but my other question is do
you really really want to know or don't
you want to watch and find out I want to
watch and find like what if I actually
answered your question right now well
you guys I would that's the truth but
also like you all would be so sad
because that's enough fun is just like
you know like I love hearing me series
because I when I watch a show I like to
pause it and drive my boyfriend crazy by
being like it's that person I know it
and I'm gonna explain it he's like hey
let's just watch the show but I'm like
no no because later on I'm going to be
like I told you you know I had fun but
like I like that the fans are able to
yeah I have a question for you when we
do find out ADEs identity will it be
because the girls have discovered who it
is or will ad reveal themselves to the
girls which is audience or to the
audience I'm going to say that it's all
kind of all of that at once which is
what makes it so brilliant okay you know
how bunch of things happen at the same
time the audience is seeing it happen
but like people are
figuring it out on their own while
you're watching it yeah I'm saying yeah
you're watching it happen as an audience
and you're like oh she just figured it
out she just figured it out they just
figured it out this reveals happening
that's what's gonna happen is it a
moment one moment yeah absolutely
is Mona in the finale known as Miss no I
feel like am i giving anyone what was it
like right there saying it wasn't like
filming that final episode lots of Tears
because everybody's coming to set is
being like you guys we have more days we
have Fulmer is our last scene together
oh my god this is our last scene
together you know but it's also so
wonderful because we know that we're
we're creating the end of our of our
stories it's been seven years in the
making and we're giving fans answers and
that's wonderful to be able to finally
say that you know when I said the other
day - I was like I can't wait to do
interviews where I no longer have to
watch what I say and we can just come in
and be like you saw it now let's really
talk about it you know I'm so sorry
yeah I've been found to have that moment
where they can be like now we know
everything it's going to be great yeah
are the fans going to be happy I think
so I think it so it's everything this is
going to be the most emotional episode
we've ever had in so many reasons you're
going to feel betrayed you're going to
feel sad you're going to feel happy it's
just going to be it's everybody just
bring tissues okay just bring tissues if
you can drink have a have a glass of
wine just because it's going to be a
journey yeah I'm just we're getting so
many different like I think ad is Emily
it's Melissa or Mona it's got to be I
well you I love this i love it because
like i said that what's fun about
watching shows that really make you
think like you can be your own detective
and how fun is that yeah and i love i
love hearing all the theories i'm not
going to say yes or no near i've got to
say though she goes Arya's ad aria can't
be ad because then she would be working
for herself
damn weird Abigail hey you know me
there's another good theory we can we
talk about avatar you talk about avatar
yeah well maybe is that it's very little
voice in the face and I'm like halfway
for me well how is that shot can you
kind of walk us through or do you know
because there's also a teaser out there
where you have all the green dots on
your face so it looks like avatar iya
had coming Tamera Monia oh yeah I'm here
with Mona Tarr well is it on
at our is it Vittoria Mon Acharya well
if it's a Matar then Mona would have to
directly be talking to ad which would be
interesting so you'll just have to wait
this sounds a mythical creature
should we catch on blanket it's like a
new Pokemon right yeah the tire comes
out of it was yeah yeah motion-capture
is weird so they put little dots on your
face I mean I'm not going to confirm or
deny what my motion capture was for but
I guess it was motion capture has weaned
and you put that on your face then you
have not and you put these little weird
dots on your face and you talk to a
camera and you can do whatever it's kind
of like snapchat filter weary me right
only a much scarier only yeah only much
scarier yeah you know we have a few more
guys are good by the way another thing
is like we doubled team I'm a little bit
like feeling a little bit ganged up on
we wanna start over there oh my god no
you guys are gonna put the pressure on
the fans right now yeah okay well
Christy says Kirstie says am I the only
one who thinks Bethany is involved we've
never seen her face what if she
Spencer's blond-haired twins not okay
that I could understand and that is
you're not on board because we never met
on TV how I forget these things to I'm
like oh yeah you never saw her face and
I feel like Katie and I have an issue
with Bethany and Sara Harvey we're just
like what was your point you saw little
Bethany yeah lash back true that is true
also when all those girls from the other
side of town are talking they mentioned
something and Avery Avery yes is that
one anything
although sign there's a time harriman
how do I can't remember either
alright I just gave that away my eyes
don't so don't pay attention to is
favorite eighty
series is Emily goes Marlena Zaidi what
do you think about it I just kind of a
day because she is our she's our puppet
master yeah these are our doll master if
you will and we're all her dolls that
live in her town true but she's a nice
ad how Indiana needs a secrecy in this
final-season what security precautions
did you guys have I'm still dealing with
it right now in this moment being like
what can I say what kind of a noting it
cuz yeah so secret and I mean we weren't
given scripts until we got there and we
had to leave them there
had our names on it so that if anything
goes out you know they can see who
accidentally slipped it to you're very
extra careful in my point and like we'd
go to seven we'd have our sides there
and you'd leave them there you don't
take them home they're making sure that
at the end of the day you give them back
so that no information gets out because
even it's like you throw it away in a
trash can you know like you just never
know so it was very very it was the most
secretive thing that I've ever been a
part of but rightfully so we want
everybody to be shocked I want you to be
shocked you know we shred them
afterwards I have a feeling that that's
exactly what happens you know that's
kind of crazy
as we start winding down I'm curious to
know what are you going to miss most
about Mona
honestly just it was an actor's dream to
play Mona they I was kept on my toes as
an actress every syndicate you'd think
you know doing a show for seven years
like you get bored and start to feel
like monotonous no never because I fell
in love with playing that character and
they gave me so much to do yeah I mean I
feel like every scene you know I'm
trying to play a different angle or I'm
trying to kind of portray a new layer
and it's fun
and it's a challenge well plus you get
like 50 different shades of exactly
that's what I mean and it was just again
it's a dream to be able to play a
character that's that's that layered
because you're constantly on your toes
as far as like how do I play this how am
I going to portray this character in
this particular scene because her brain
is always in some different place of
what she wants at that moment and it's
fun to play it up do you have a favorite
Mona episode no in a moment I do have a
favorite Mona episode it has not aired
yet uh-oh is one of these are valid it's
not the finale
it's oh it's the episode before the
finale why is it why is it your favorite
I feel like have me on after and we'll
discuss it when you come back I D like I
had some really fun scenes that I really
enjoyed playing with okay I will come
back yeah yeah it is a different side of
Mona that we haven't seen maybe a little
bit maybe a little bit yeah I think I
think she lets her guard down in some
ways and you you start to you start to
learn a little bit more about her and
why she is was she is loved that honesty
that you know yeah thank you so much for
having ideas on the roast of red
we really appreciate it and thank you
all to all you fans for sending in your
series you guys keep crushing it thanks
again so much you're watching ichi live
i'm leanna Galera
I'm Katie Crowder and that was just help
yeah